so hi my name is maria and um i am an
interaction designer and my talk is
called design developer collaboration
best practices so i have a quick agenda
for you guys we have just like 25
minutes to go through the whole thing
so i'll touch a little bit on the
graphic design and then on ui ux design
mention some lean and agile practices
processes that we have processes we want
some tools
that designers work with like imagine
i'm a designer and then here at
basically a developer conference so
i will want to give you some insight on
how designers work
how it's uh
done with distributed teams different
size projects and maybe also mention
briefly some open source design
practices and communities
so why am i doing this talk basically uh
as far as i can remember as long as i've
been working with open source with
fedora and red hat there's always been
some issue collaborating with developers
first of all because developers have
different processes uh oftentimes the
teams are set up so they are agile so
they're working in sprints and
developers have their own tasks and they
have their own statuses for these tasks
and they do not always match whatever
designers are doing
and also i've been a long time
contributor for fedora
and as you know fedora is
in many ways working distributed all
over the world so
the
people who contribute to fedora can live
in australia in the us
anywhere europe in
you name it
and it's also always been a challenge
collaborating online and now in covetous
obviously
many teams are online and it poses much
more challenges that way
on how to for everybody to collaborate
even if you know developers and
designers working different ways now
there's an added challenge of doing it
remotely
and from my point of view better
understanding between the two
i don't want to call them teams but the
two different professions would lead to
better collaboration and greater results
throughout for you for yourself
and for your users
in the end
okay so
hopefully you will get some insight into
designing work what's your iex graphic
design and what i mentioned already
tools processing tasks
okay so let me talk a little bit more
about who i am
so at the moment i'm working as an
interaction designer i've been attracted
for six and a half years and i'm mostly
focused on
uh products that are
working inside of red house so some
internal tools
but also i've been a long time
contributor to fedora and i started as a
fedora design intern so working on the
fedora design team
for i think seven years now
and uh i will start at that because i
started as a graphic designer than
slowly transitioning to be
a user experience designer or an
interaction designer
if you will so i will start a little bit
about talking a little bit about the
graphic design process
uh so in fedora design team we use a
ticketing system
and it's on packer
and we have a specific place set up for
it so it's tiger design issues and the
issues
come in here so if you want to request
anything from fedora design team so
something fedora related maybe you want
a logo maybe you want some swag maybe
you want a banner um anything that's
you know graphic
that would go in there so the ticket
comes in it's triad so somebody looks at
it is assigned to a designer designer
works on that issue so they create some
design for you
then uh there's some feedback from other
designers we do hold design meetings i
think
once every two weeks at this moment
and then all we also like to get some
feedback from the requester obviously
because if you requested the design
you know what you need and we would like
to hear from you once the design is
created because normally the designer
when they work they do not just create
this one design
well i shouldn't say normally but
sometimes they would create one design
that they think you requested one design
maybe that they like maybe something
else comes to their mind they want to
you know as a professional to offer that
to you and we would like to hear from
you basically to get some feedback
then based on the feedback they would
iterate and
once the design is approved you're done
so graphic design process is pretty uh
linear so
you get a ticket you work on it you
finish and you're done because you get
something tangible in the end you get a
logo
uh you get an icon or a set of icons you
get a wallpaper for that matter like
throw a wallpaper for example it's
something we work on
once it's done it's it's you know done
all right so the tools that we use
and on the left here i
mentioned the tools that fedora
uses for their designs and on the right
i also mentioned some paid tools if we
are not talking specifically about open
source projects but rather any sort of
graphic design
uh here i want to point out specifically
uh parker that was for ticketing
inkscape that's a great factor
tool to work with vector images and
actual graphics uh if you're editing
some photos you would want to use
if you're working on something more
complicated maybe some interface or a
website you would you could possibly use
plantpod and that's something that we
started to use recently
and the all the
talking right now chatting happens on
matrix or element
and we also use mailing lists and at
some points github is used to store some
graphic work okay so some of the
challenges that up here that we face
working with developers
is sometimes people ask us for the wrong
thing
so something that's not in the capacity
of the design thing for that matter
maybe it should go to marketing or some
other
field or sometimes incomplete
information in the ticket because for
example if you're requesting a logo you
cannot just say okay i need a lot of
logo for my you know team or my project
we would want to know something else
like
who you are what your project does do
you have any idea what it should look
like
maybe
you also would be welcome to leave a lot
of feedback because it sometimes happens
that the designer would create something
and then the original requester would
never come back to the ticket and they
would not leave anything
what they like what they don't like or
anything like that
sometimes they do with feedback but it
can be off-putting so be mindful about
what you write some of the contributors
can be very new
a lot of people like to try out
their design skills in in the design
team so you should
be more guiding not off-booting when
you're
writing something in the ticket
so you should be mindful that those
people are volunteer workers that they
could maybe you would not be able to
handle all of your requests or maybe
they don't you know they only do it in
their free time and so they won't have
they would want able to be
i'm sorry they won't be able to do it
very quickly
anyway some of the advice and just
generally working with the global team
of designers and ticketing system
is to have well-defined well-documented
tasks and maybe some you know resources
available but that's mostly for us not
for the developers
for the developers that would be you
know know how to submit your requests um
and here i'm saying developers i
generally think everybody uh who needs
something design
created right so be mindful what types
of tasks you're considering for the
design team uh think about what info we
might need from you or be there to
answer questions should we need more
um and like i mentioned so you know the
time frames can be longer because people
are distributed people do it in their
free time they might have their you know
their main job and they will just you
know do some
fedora design or
after hours
and the most important part is the two
way feedbacks always remember to be
there to answer questions to provide
feedback and also
may be hard but sometimes it's needful
to trust the expert so trust the
designers that are working on your
project
um probably they have a good perspective
on what they're doing
okay
so going on from there
that was a little bit of an intro into
fedora design team i'm gonna go on and
talk a little bit about ux so use your
experience design and you are using
interaction design
uh so if you access more of a broad term
that sort of incorporates ui in it
because you access something that we're
talking about when we talk about
experiences and so if we talk about ux
design it's a lot of things in one
so it's testing it's writing user
stories it's creating personas doing
research writing scenarios creating
wireframes creating prototypes
well
ui is mostly concerned with interfaces
right so it's mostly about how that
looks not how it feels
so all sorts layouts colors typography
and
it's
important to remember that these two
need to work together because as you can
see in this picture
somebody designed this road to go this
way right so somebody designed this
park i think but then the user
experience is completely different so
they didn't you know look at the user
behavior prior to designing this and
this is in my head the main difference
and something you need to always
consider that you should design based on
whatever people tell you anyway
there's a
quick representation of what i was
talking about so this is ux and this is
ui right here
okay um
going on to
the whole collaboration i'm still
leading into that
um
i want to touch briefly on how ui and dx
design is different from graphic design
process so
as you saw the graphic design is very
linear so you get a task you work on it
as a designer and then it's done and you
you are done
the main thing here is that you're never
really done and then you should also
collaborate throughout the process not
as a request comes in you do it and you
ship it off
uh no ideally a good ui ux designer
depending on what they do will be
involved from the start so they will be
involved in the strategy and research
they're working with developers from the
very start working with product owners
with qa with everybody
and they should be sure they're solving
the right problem so the user has also
to be involved from the very start
and the good ux designer would
advocate for the needs of the user from
the very start
some of the tools that i used here
and i want to mention the tools because
it's very important that not only
designers try and understand how
developers in the input their designs
into life uh so it's good for a designer
for example know some code to know maybe
some html basic css at least
when they are working at their backups
to ensure that they can be done or at
least work with the developer from the
very start to to you know
ensure that the mockups are feasible
that they would not have to change their
design drastically although they've not
designed something totally crazy
that cannot be done in the end i have to
redesign it
okay so the tools are so some designers
start with pen and paper some can use a
graphic tablet to draw their stuff
very basic at first
then they can use inkscape or sketch
which is
a commercial product that you have to
pay for
to put the wireframes together
um
here's an example of a very basic design
so it's very you know locality mid
fidelity wireframe this is more
detailed wireframe and from there you
can test already at this point with your
user or at least with someone on your
team maybe one or two people you can
show them get their feedback see if
you're going in the right direction
um specifically the developer needs to
be involved at this point already so
they can see
okay so this can be done this makes
sense maybe that doesn't make sense
maybe that interaction won't work in the
android
and then you could use other tools like
um sketch for example or that which i
mentioned already or figma or anything
else there is a lot of them
to put your detailed prototypes together
and the important part here is that they
would be interactive so you can assign
specific parts of your prototype to be
clickable like this button if you click
this button it does this because
oftentimes you cannot just hand over
and finish design like you could in
graphic design so okay here's the
picture and you're done uh no you have
to design the whole experience
throughout so when the user does this
this happens this this screen appears
when user does this that screen appears
that kind of thing
um
some of the challenges here
are pretty much the same
as we mentioned before but also
sometimes when there's no clear
understanding of what the goals are who
the user is
once there's no clear direction then the
team can steer off in a little bit of a
you know wrong path and start designing
that way so you need to always check
back are you solving the right problem
get to the bottom of it get get to the
to your user ask them is this right is
this right for you
um
again i hear i mention insufficient
feedback
so a design does not happen in a vacuum
you always need someone to bounce your
ideas off of to make uh to to make sure
it makes sense maybe if you're designing
an interface somebody has some example
that you could use maybe they have a
better idea than you that you could put
together
and that's totally fine
um one of the most important things is
to design a handoff
and
specifically i want to mention this
because sometimes it so happens that the
person designed something they would
design an interface they would give it
to the developer and think okay
that's it well ideally no because when
the developer starts putting it together
many things can happen
uh they can put it together a bit
differently maybe
they don't understand what the
interaction is
it's not easy to document interactions
and it's not easy in the distributed
team for that matter to explain
something
i always say that it's easier to show
once than you know to explain in in two
pages of text how the design works
so
you would want to you know design
something and then work with the
developers show them
explain to them
hopefully if you can talk to them if you
can video chat them at least
to do that
and also it can be difficult because
people speak different languages so
designers have their orange organ
developers have their own jargon and it
can be challenging to understand each
other
so some of the solutions are listed here
uh also i want to mention uh this third
bullet here maintain contact with team
members throughout um and that means
that
with the distributed team we don't often
see each other maybe in some team
meetings or maybe not even ever
and it's hard to understand how the
person you're working with
likes to work how do they like to
get the word to them
for example some people would like it if
you would talk to them a lot if you
would call them from time to time or
maybe if you would other people would
like it if they you write them messages
or if you email them everybody is very
different everybody's processes are
different
some people would like to check in with
you all the time some people would never
do that
and one more advice would be to just
maybe set up a video call if possible
with your team member who you're working
with
and i i don't know how many developers
are in the audience or if there are any
designers or maybe some other
specialists
so i i
i would like to know that at some point
but yeah it's very important to just
check in with the person maybe nothing
even work related maybe just set up a
video call and chat about life so you
get to know this person better because
everybody
works differently and to maintain this
kind of human contact is very important
um
another thing i want to mention is the
design systems and there was a talk
earlier today about design system which
i thought was great and i mentioned that
i want to mention two more i want to
mention pattern fly
that is used wise widely um
for products and also i would mention
youngster treadhead.com so it's just a
site that contains a lot of components
that can be used and reused in different
interfaces which might be helpful
because sometimes for developer if they
get a picture um
they need to know how what what's the
size of the elements is basically what's
the color
because the designers can put a lot of
thought into that but it's not easy to
read from the picture
and so just to
think this through how you want to hand
off the designs how the person
who would put them together
maybe a front-end developer how they
would work with it
some of the tools that i mentioned
online they offer an option to inspect
the design so you could see
what the size of the element is and how
you could put it in code
or maybe you could directly copy code
from there and that's much easier for
everybody
i want to also mention briefly here the
open design framework and
um
this link works but anyway so that's
something that the whole team agrees on
so that's the tools that's the processes
that's how these site tickets are
incorporated into developer tickets and
their processes
and also how
maybe the personas are set up for your
process let me speed up a little bit
because i don't have much time left all
right and so i also wanted to mention
all the new acts which is a sort of
that's a process that's been uh
incorporated a couple years back and so
that
allows you to focus on the outcome so
not to build a whole product from start
to end with a lot of bells and whistles
and features but rather build something
that's
an mvp so the minimum viable product
it's the core concept of lineac so if
you build something that's
that once
functional reliable usable introduce
maybe some emotional design it's focused
on your user it's tested throughout but
it works and and maybe it's minimal but
that can be built upon
rather than it's just functional does
that
okay so what else can be done
um you also
can hold design thinking workshops and
here i'm going to do a quick plug-in
tomorrow uh maureen norton and i are
holding a design thinking workshop in
the afternoon and you're welcome to come
we're going to do some uh descending
exercises and don't be put off by the
word design it's
more of a way of thinking not of
designing stuff
one more thing is design reviews it's
something i like to do
on the teams that i work on so i would
invite everybody who's on the team and
who can come so we can look at designs
we can talk together we can see if we
agree on what needs to happen
um
and just you know agree on further steps
and always people have a lot of great
ideas that we could incorporate in the
designs later
uh here i wanted to mention that there
are a lot of processes
that exist like design thinking lean
agile anything
and unfortunately it's impossible to
solve the whole design developer
collaboration problem with a process
it really really depends on how the team
is set up on how the developers work and
maybe it can be different for every
single
process and let me just get briefly to
hear a project right because different
projects are different sized and so they
have
different stages something maybe shorter
something maybe longer
but
you know you have to be mindful of that
and as a designer working with a
developer you have to be mindful of that
too let me go back one second i also
want to mention briefly as a closing
maybe almost know
the 10 usability heuristics um
i will so my slides are posted on uh
said.org so you can
download them or
you unhappy i don't know
so i will be sharing my slides after the
talk
and i want everybody to be mindful of
these heuristics they are very useful
i i have them printed out so i'll think
about them all the time
and i think for developers too it should
be very useful to think about this to
just you know to keep your user in mind
to keep
their um
behavior in mind and to help them out
when you're building something
um also these are some process diagrams
that exist
and this is ideally what would happen
when you're working on a project but
it's not always what would happen
and here you could see
um
what and maybe even who is involved at
each stage
and ideally all the team or
developers and designers for that matter
would be involved from start to end so
they talk together constantly so they
can reiterate so they understand so
they're on the same page and they talk
to each other
not forgetting about the user
okay so
i guess with this i'll close and we'll
have a short q a maybe you could give me
some advice on how to work with
developers better because i
would love to see who's in the audience
today
and if you have any questions and let me